Here's the thing.
Even when he was a two o five pounder,
right.
And he had a tendency to gas out,
gas out and get,
you know,
be Chiney to a degree.
But he was always super technical,
highly skilled.
Like I don't think you could Overeem,
him and his brother both are actually very good fighters and you know,
their struggles have never been a physical one for the most part.
I think,
you know,
they've had,
and that's a difficulty that that is most common amongst fighters is the mental
game of it.
Well,
we saw that with,
in Ghana this week.
Yeah.
We seen the fight,
but I heard it was,
it was one for the ages.
It was one for the ages.
Let some lines loosened that thing and just like,
okay,
let's crank this up a bit.
It was the worst heavyweight fight I've ever seen.
It was the worst a of mine before he came down to,
it came down to the sea.
It was the second lowest output fight ever.
Uh,
so they couldn't even make it the lowest output fight to be number one.
I didn't even get to number one.
Number one nail is they failed that failing Jens Pulver versus Joe Hoke from
like a fucking UFC 13 or some shit him and know what day that fight was,
but that fight was number one with 23 or 22 strikes landed in three rounds and
this fight was number two at 23 strikes landed.
That's weird dude.
It was insane.
And then ovary,
I mean a Francis go to Francis and Ganos Instagram.
He released a statement today and his statement was essentially that he was a
over,
he carried the fear.
He said,
I'm not proud of my last performance.
I have applied to this one.
I completely understand the frustration,
anger that it's caused my fans,
coaches,
teammates and family and friends,
weird that he would have fear from the last fight.
We got fucking owned,
wrestle.
He didn't know.
He thought he was the man and then he got owned and then won't.
But he's letting everyone down again.
All I can do now is proved myself and make you proud again.
But look at this picture that he puts up his swinging on him,
him,
him connected one punch.
Yeah.
I mean that's kind of funny.
It should have been him with his head down,
Frances in the future,
if you're gonna,
if you're gonna post a humble shot,
look humble.
Yeah.
This is like I'm calling him.
I can't say that,
that he doesn't legitimately made,
maybe he is carrying some kind of fear from the last fight in terms of losing
the result or is a lot of mind fuck that can go into being a fighter and yeah.
But uh,
I think with bounce back,
you've been on both sides and you know,
the first fight back after a kale loss or after getting dominated,
what does that feeling like?
Yeah.
I don't know.
I've been at this shit for so long that for me it's just like,
all right,
that was then,
this is now don't make the same mistakes.
What you've experienced,
everything you've been submitted,
you've been knocked out,
you've knock guys out,
you submitted guys,
you've won the title,
you beat some of the best guys in the world.
You've had fantastic performances.
You'd have performances that frustrated you,
you've experienced at all you've got,
I mean,
in your long career.
from being the youngest ever heavyweight champion of the world ever.
To how old are you now?
40 40 man.
Dude,
you fucking seen it all.
You've literally seen it all.